As we go to cycle 3, again we can free this reservation station.
The instruction has been dispatched. So, in cycle 3 we have,
this reservation station free again. Don't forget to do that because you might
run out of reservation stations pretty much surely otherwise. So in cycle 3,
we are going to try to issue this instruction here, it's an ad. So
we check that we have this type of reservation station. Do we have ROB entries,
yes we do have both. So what we going to do is we going to issue this
instruction. It's an add, it tries to R3, R3 is now renamed to Rob3.
We mark here that we are issuing this add and we put this add here.
The name of the result is Rob3, because we just put this instruction here.
We check R7 and R8. They are renamed to. Just the Register file,
so we can just take those values of 1 and 2 and this instruction is ready to
dispatch,which means it will begin executing the next cycle. It takes only one
cycle to execute so in, cycle 5, it's actually going to try to write the result.
And, now that we have successfully renamed this instruction and so on,
we don't have anything else to do in cycle 3 basically. These two instructions.
I'm not going to write anything on the broadcast box yet.
So with that we can move on to cycle 4. In cycle 4 the add begins execution and
at the beginning of cycle 4, we already have this entry free because we
have this patch in the previous cycles. So now we're going to try to issue this
instruction here we have our free reservation station. We have free ROB entries
so it will be able to ensure in cycle 4, it's going to take his ROB entry.
It will write to R1 so we remember that. We take also a reservation station.
We say that we're going to be broadcasting ROB4 when we do this. now what we do
is, for this instruction we're going to look at the RAT before we update it
to see where would we find our Registers that we're going to use as samples.
We are using R1 and R3. R1 and R3 map to ROB2 and
ROB3. So we actually mark here ROB2 and ROB3.
And we don't have values yet, so this instruction actually will have to wait.
It will not be able to dispatch now because it's actually waiting for, this is
just ROB2 and ROB3, I'm not writing it out because, it would be too crowded.
And after we have read these from the RAT, we are ready to update the RAT.
R1 now needs to point to ROB4. Be careful when you update the RAT.
You first need to check whether you find your register inputs, and
then you rename for your outputs. Because if one of your inputs gets overwritten
with your output, you first need to use the values of the RAT before you rename.
Otherwise, you would, the instruction would be. Waiting for
it's own result which will never happen. So
now R1 begins to point at ROB4 because that's going to be the latest R1 that we,
we're going to produce. And this instruction will not be able to execute here.
It's actually going to execute once both of these operands are ready. So
this basically finishes cycle 4. And we are ready to see what happens in cycle 5